Hello
bitches.
Now I want to switch gears a little bit.
That's not,
it's not totally related,
but it is in somewhat in some ways headspace.
Um,
talking about mindsets and talking about like we've brought this up but really
haven't delved into it much at all about meditation and about how much it's
affected you and how it got you back on track.
And I know that you're a big proponent of it and I am as well,
although I think I'd probably do it differently than you guys do,
but I'd love to hear how,
how you do it by using an isolation tank.
Oh really?
Like a sensory deprivation tank.
Yeah,
yeah.
I do a lot of yoga.
Those are,
those are two big ones for me.
You know,
I think,
um,
those alone have straightened out my brain in a great way of yoga in particular
yoga because it's,
um,
it's not yoga forces you to do it,
you know,
like if you,
you're either doing it or you're not doing it,
there's no room for distraction.
You know,
you're,
you're essentially forced to deal with what these poses require of you.
And I think that in,
in doing so and having a singular focus of trying to,
uh,
maintain your balance and stretch and extend and do all these different things,
why you do it,
then concentrating almost entirely on your breath,
which is a big factor in yoga that it's uh,
it has remarkable brain scrubbing attributes.
Yeah,
I would say,
and I don't know much before I say this,
let me just ask,
what are you doing in the isolation tank?
Like what are you doing in your mind a lot?
Well,
you know,
do you use it for a bunch of different in a bunch of different ways?
I don't use it as much as I should honestly.
Um,
but I
concentrate on and sometimes I go in there with uh,
uh,
an idea like all concentrate on material like that I'm working on or maybe
Jujitsu techniques and I'm having problems with or,
um,
some other things I'm dealing with,
you know,
any,
any sort of issues and a half.
Sometimes I do that.
Sometimes it just go in there and chill out and relax and breathe and
concentrate.
There's a lot of physical things that happen inside the tank.
Um,
there's the amount of magnesium that's a in the water because it's Epsom salts.
It's really good for you physically.
It's very good for the muscles.
It loosens you up and relax as you,
and that eliminates a lot of stress.
And that physical elimination of stress allows the brain to function with a just
less pressure and allows you to relax more and puts things in perspective
better.
And it also,
it gives you this a environment that's not available anywhere else in the
planet.
This wait list,
floating,
disconnected from your body environment where you're,
you don't hear anything,
you don't see anything,
you don't feel anything.
You feel like you're weightless,
you,
you have this um,
sensation of flying because you're totally weightless,
weightless in the dark.
You Open your eyes,
you don't see anything,
you close your eyes.
It's exactly the same.
The water's the same temperatures,
your skin so you don't feel the water and you're floating.
I'll say this hand on the share of this is going to let it go down.
I actually don't have any questions about the,
the,
the benefits of being in an isolation tank even though I don't know too much
about it.
And I also am a PR,
I think yoga great.
Although I don't do much of it myself.
I I think though that there may actually be a difference between those two
activities and meditation because it is a kind of,
this is of Highfalutin term metacognition serve knowing what you know or knowing
that you're thinking,
uh,
that happens in the kind of mindfulness meditation,
of which,
uh,
Sam and I are proponents proponents that I think is a different thing where
you're seeing,
and I'll just try to put this in English,
when you're meditating the way we do,
you're seeing how crazy you are.
You're seeing you're fucking nuts.
And that actually has a real value is systematic collision with the asshole in
your head has a real value because when the asshole offers you up a shitty
suggestion in the rest of your life,
which is basically it's job like,
oh yeah,
you should eat the 17th cookie or say the thing that's going to ruin the next 48
hours of your marriage or whatever.
You're better able to resist it.
So what?
Like what do you do?
So I'm in the basic steps of mindfulness,
meditation,
artists,
it most people close their eyes.
You bring your full attention to the feeling of your breath,
just the,
you're not thinking about your breath,
you just feeling the raw data of the physical sensations.
And then the third step is the Biggie,
which is as soon as you try to do this,
your mind's going to go bonkers.
You're going to start thinking about what's for lunch,
doing eight a haircut,
where to gerbils run wild,
whatever,
blah,
blah.
You're just going to notice,
oh,
I'm,
my mind is going crazy right now.
But that noticing is the key moment is in fact the victory.
It's interesting because this is when most people think they've failed that
because,
oh,
I can't meditate because I can't clear my mind is the biggest misconception
about meditation.
You do not need to clear your mind.
That's impossible unless you're enlightened or dead.
Uh,
the whole goal is just to notice when you've become distracted and start again.
You return your attention to your breath and you just do that a million times.
And every time you catch yourself wondering and go back to your breath,
it's a bicep curl for your brain.
It changes your brain.
And,
um,
that over time creates the kind of metacognition I was discussing before where
you see that you're a homo sapiens,
sapiens and other words,
Euro.
Uh,
that's how it were classified as a species.
We are the one who thinks and knows he or she thinks and that just that knowing
that you have this voice in your head,
uh,
as Sam likes to joke,
he feels like when he thinks about the voice in his head,
he feels like he's been hijacked by the most boring person alive.
Just says the same shit over and over.
Um,
uh,
a joke that I,
I deal from him all the time.
Yeah.
Uh,
that,
that is enormously powerful because then you are not held hostage by this voice.
A similar thing happens in the tank.
Um,
I do,
uh,
do a form of meditation in the tank.
Sometimes when I go in there with or without an idea,
like if I'm not working on material or anything else where I just concentrating
on my breath in,
through the nose,
out through the mouth,
and I just literally concentrate on the breath.
And the same thing happens to meditation.
We,
yeah,
we,
yeah.
It's,
it's not similar.
It's the exact same thing.
The differences in the tank.
After a while,
after about 20 minutes or so,
that breaks loose to psychedelic states.
Wow.
Hmm.
Have you ever combine the tank with psychedelics?
Altered state?
So yeah.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Trip what?
LSD Or,
or mushrooms.
Mushrooms.
But the big one is edible pot.
Edible pod seems to be as strong as anything in there.
I've,
I eat enough pot where I'm convinced I'm gonna die and then I climb in there and
write every time.
I do it.
I go,
don't do that again cause I just get out.
So terrifying.
What's your motivation when you're eating the pot and climbing into this?
Nice,
let's see what happens.
Okay.
Yeah.
Just be scared.
Be terrified because,
yeah,
because nothing ever happens.
You never die,
but God damn you just convinced that the universe is imploding around you and
that it is so it usually has the,
the character of fear being made part of it.
It's also not embracing the fear,
not letting the fear run rampant and just sort of relaxing and giving into the
vulnerability your,
the finite nature of your existence and just breathing and concentrating and
letting,
letting the dance take place because there's some,
there's some sort of a weird,
one of the things that,
there's a big misconception about when it comes to edible pot,
is it edible pod is like smoking pot.
It's an entirely different process.
Physiologically your liver at the time course is very different to him.
You can stay stolen for three days.
Yeah,
you can.
You could fuck up and eat too many brownies and you'll be gone for a long time.
That sounds miserable.
It is.
But it's not because he gets something out of it.
When it's over the,
the,
the process is excruciating.
But when you come out of it,
you just feel so happy.
I feel so happy.
It's,
yeah.
It's like that joke about the dude.
He's banging his head up against the wall and somebody says,
why are you doing that?
And he says,
because it feels so good when I stopped.
Hm.
In a way,
but there's no physical damage banging your head up against the wall.
You're gonna hurt yourself.
This is true.
Uh,
yeah.
I don't know.
I think there seems like there might be easier ways to get to the same wisdom
[inaudible]
maybe.
But I think there's also creativity that gets inspired by the edible pot.
Something called 11 hydroxy metabolite that your body produces.
It's,
it's so different than most people when they eat pot,
they think they've been dosed.
Like anybody who's smoked pot before,
and then you give him a Brownie,
they think,
oh my God,
there's something in that.
And they're convinced because reality itself just seems like it just dissolves.
And especially inside the tank.
There's something about the tank environment that produces.
In the absence of any external stimuli,
your brain becomes sort of supercharged because what you're trying to do when
you're just sitting down and concentrating and relaxing as you're trying to
focus on your thoughts,
but you're still aware of your body is still aware of your elbows touching this
desk,
your butt touching the chair.
There's all these different factors that that are theirs,
stimuli that's coming into your,
your your senses.
Whereas in the tank there's none of that virtually.
It's almost completely eliminated.
There's some,
but you can,
you can,
you can phase that stuff out.
Like you could still feel the water a little bit.
If you think about it,
you could still,
sometimes you bump into the wall and you have to like center yourself and you
have to look,
relax again and make sure you're not moving so that you don't touch things which
can kind of dissolve the experience,
their experiences.
Meditation where you have that same experience where you lose your sense of the
body,
but that usually comes with more concentration.
You have to be very concentrated on it.
I feel like you would have that experience and it would be even more intense if
you did the exact same thing that you do outside the tank in the tank.
I don't think you need any psychedelics and the tango.
It's one thing I tell people when they ask me,
should I get high before I do it?
And like,
no,
just do it.
Just do it.
If you decide after a while,
if you'd done it three or four times and you're like,
I wonder what it's like if I just take a little bit of a hit of pot and see
where it takes me.
And there's nothing wrong with that.
It's not gonna hurt you.
You know?
If you're a type of person,
enjoys marijuana or whatever,
but that the tank alone by itself,
just the absence of sensory input,
your brain goes to a very,
very different place.
And as long as you can relax and as long as you don't think too much about the
fact that you're in the tank and just concentrate and Thailand your thoughts
entirely on your breath.
And again,
let all those crazy like where to hamsters live,
like all that shit.
Let let all that stuff run wild through your mouth.
But I feel like in the tank at least that gets to a certain spot.
Then it stops existing and then the psychedelic state techs over.
Yeah,
well it depends on what the goal is.
I think there can be many different goals of meditation or in a quasi spiritual
practice and then they're not there.
They're distinct.
So the center of the Bullseye for me is not suffering unnecessarily.
Right.
So and so one thing that that mindfulness gives you is,
so it's Patina,
it's compatible with every experience you can have.
I mean there is nothing in your experience that isn't inappropriate object of
meditation.
You just,
most people start with the breath because it's just a very convenient thing to
start with.
But once you know how to do this particular practice,
you're just,
your goal is to just be clearly aware of whatever your experience is in each
moment.
So it's emotions arise,
thoughts arise,
sounds come in your,
your,
your attention is wide open to whatever your experience is.
So it's not like,
so nothing in principle is a distraction.
I mean that could be,
you could be meditating right next to a construction site and the sound of of
the hammers is just as good an object of meditation as the breath or anything
else.
So there's nothing,
everything is included.
But the,
the,
the super power you're after,
which you actually can acquire through this practice is to realize that
virtually all of your,
of your psychological suffering and actually arguably virtually all of your,
your physical suffering.
I mean the,
or the,
the difference between physical pain and suffering,
which I mean those two are not quite the same thing.
Um,
is a matter of being lost in thought.
It's a matter of thinking without knowing that you're thinking and what and what
mindfulness does.
And really any technique of meditation ultimately should do is teach you to
break the spell of being lost in thought and to notice a thought as a thought.
I mean the,
the,
the huge difference is until you learn how to meditate or do something like
meditation,
you're just helplessly thinking every moment of your life you're having a
conversation with yourself.
You're having content,
whether it's imagistic or linguistic pour forth into consciousness every moment
and so incessantly that you don't even notice it.
It's just white noise.
And not only does it completely color your experience moment to moment.
So like if you're,
if they're angry thoughts,
you're angry.
If they're depressed thoughts or you're depressed or sad that you're sad.
So you become your thoughts,
but you also feel,
you feel,
you feel identified,
you feel that you are the thinker of your thoughts.
You feel like a self.
And it's a completely structured by this flow of,
of mentation every moment.
And it produces everything you do.
It produces all of your intentions and your goals and your actions.
And he said this about me and now I'm going to say this.
I mean,
so it's like,
it's everything coming out to you is born of of this the same process.
And meditation is a way of recognizing that consciousness and that what you are
subjectively as a,
this prior condition of just be awareness in which everything is showing up,
sounds sensations and thoughts and thoughts can become just other objects of
consciousness.
And,
um,
so I'm going to take a,
at a very basic,
uh,
example of the difference between pain and suffering.
You can feel very strong physical pain,
I mean unpleasant pain and
just be aware of it in that like the,
the sense that it's unbearable is virtually always untrue because you in that
moment you've already born it,
right?
That may have,
what did the feeling that something's unbearable is really the fear of having to
experience it in the next moment in the future.
Right.
Cause you're always like if,
if,
if some,
if someone drives a nail into your knee,
right?
You might,
well that's uh,
that sounds like it's unbearable,
but every moment you are feeling it,
your bearing it,
right.
It's like,
it's,
it's what you're,
what you're thinking about is the last moment and the next moment,
and you're thinking about how much oil,
you know,
when am I going to get some relief?
And you know,
what's the cure and how badly is my knee injured?
like you're,
you're,
you're worried about the future continuously and you're not noticing the
automaticity of thought that is,
that is amplifying the,
the,
the negative negativity of the experience in that moment.
And we all know that you can have super intense sensation,
which is either either pleasant or unpleasant depending on the,
on the conceptual frame you've put around it.
So for instance,
if,
if you had this massive sense of soreness in your shoulder,
that you would experience it very differently if it was a,
the result of you dead lifting more than you ever had in your life,
and you are proud of it,
right?
Um,
B probably cancer and you're waiting for your,
you know,
the,
the biopsy results and,
and,
uh,
you know,
you're worried about,
this is the thing,
the thing that's gonna kill you.
Or you're getting raw food,
you know,
like some deep tissue massage and it hurts like hell,
but you actually totally understand the source of the pain that you know it's
going to be gone the moment the guy pulls his elbow back,
right?
So it could be the exact same sensation,
each one of those,
but the conceptual frame you have around it totally dictates the level of
psychological suffering and or,
or the conducted the total absence of psychological suffering.
Now we were talking before the podcast started about your apps and we were
talking about the amount of different meditation exercises on the apps.
Like what kind of different meditation exercises are there?
If you're talking about just concentrating on mindfulness and breathing,
uh,
as it turns out,
you can iterate off of that basic exercise in some to,
to like,
uh,
infinity essentially.
Um,
because you talk about not only,
well,
I don't want to get too ahead of myself,
but basically the,
the,
the basic instructions are that we listed before.
You're feeling your breath coming in and then when you get lost,
you start again.
But then you can add onto that.
So one big thing to add on is something called mental noting.
So you're breathing in and out and you're feeling your breath and then you get
distracted by huge wave of anger.
Generally speaking,
when we get hit by a wave of anger,
we just inhabit the anger.
We become angry.
There's no buffer between the stimulus and our response to it.
But there's this little technique you can do of just making a little mental note
of,
Oh,
that's anger and that kind of objectifies and the thing,
it's a little bit like pressing the picture in picture button on your uh,
rook control,
where the story that's taken up the whole frame can be seen with some uh,
perspective.
Uh,
so that's just one example of the little techniques that you can add onto the
basic exercise.
And you can go for a long time.
So as we were discussing,
Sam's bout to start his meditation APP,
which is going to be called what Santam waking up.
And I have mine,
which is called 10% happier.
Sam is going to be doing all the teaching on his APP.
And My,
on my absence,
I'm not a teacher.
We,
we have experts coming in like Joseph Goldstein,
who's again the friend of a friend of both Sam and I,
uh,
and you,
each teacher has their own emphasis and you then start talking about applied
meditation.
So how do I use it when we're,
how do I use in my everyday life?
How do I use it?
If really what I want to do right now is,
um,
control my eating.
So meditation for example,
we have a course on the APP that talks about using it to not overeat.
By the way,
I'm terrible at this,
but you can use your ability,
your mindfulness,
your ability to know what's happening in your head at any given moment without
getting carried away by it,
to not overeat.
Notice,
Oh,
I'm having this urge right now to eat as I did last night and an entire bag of
malted,
uh,
chocolate in my hotel room.
Uh,
but I don't,
I can ride that urge and not do the thing that I know is stupid.
Um,
so anyway,
that's just a little taste of how you can take meditation and bring it in kind
of numerous directions.
Do you guys feel competitive?
Both of apps?
No,
his isn't even that mindset,
let's say.
Not yet.
When his comes out and completely cannibalize his mind then,
then yeah.
How happy is for me,
I actually 10% happier.
I'll be like negative 500%.
What's 10% of zero?
Yeah,
exactly.
No,
I actually think I'm of the view,
you know,
now that I've been in this meditation APP business for a little while,
I'm kind of,
I don't think it's Uber,
I don't think the business model is that there's just one huge app everybody
uses and maybe there's some distant,
you know,
second,
I actually think it's more,
a little bit more like fast food.
I think he's going to be a bunch of big players and uh,
and you may switch back and forth.
Um,
do I think it's one need a nap?
No,
no,
you don't.
But
I mean,
the thing that's useful and it's really useful at any level of expertise in,
in meditation and they at least this kind of meditation,
is it having someone guide you?
Yeah,
it's,
it's like a,
uh,
a mindfulness alarm that's constantly going off or going off it,
you know,
periodically over the course of 10 minutes or 20 minutes or however long you're
sitting,
and because distraction is just continually the problem and you either
meditating or you're distracted,
you're,
you're either,
that you're,
they're aware of what's happening at that moment or you're lost in thought.
And that's true throughout your life.
I mean,
you're either hearing what I'm saying right now,
or you're thinking about something else and you don't know it,
right?
Or you're,
you're either reading the book you're intending to read or your mind is
wandering.
You're going to have to read that paragraph again.
So this,
this failure to concentrate,
this failure to be able to focus on what you're intending to focus on,
is it just this,
this universal problem of human consciousness?
And so meditation trains that and the other benefits follow.
But the having a voice in your head reminding you that you're even attempting to
be meditating is a very powerful,
yeah.
Even if you're,
even if it's your own voice.
I mean,
even in when I'm listening to a meditation that I recorded,
just my own voice,
remember it reminded me that I'm,
that I'm supposed to be meditating.
Um,
it works like any other voice,
you know,
and it's,
um,
so it's,
it's just,
it's a feedback system that you can't really provide for yourself.
Although you,
obviously you can,
I mean,
you can meditate without an app and most people do.
And I've spent very little time meditating with apps.
I just think they're very useful.
But you,
you know,
both of us started meditating.
You started meditating well before I did,
but we both started pre the apps the morning around.
Um,
uh,
so you can read,
you can read a book,
read a good book,
and learn how to meditate out of the book,
um,
and just basically remember the basic instructions and do it.
Uh,
but he really is useful to have an APP,
especially for some people because of one of the biggest problems in meditation
is this persistent fear that you're not doing it right.
And so to have a voice you trust in your ear,
just giving you,
reminding you of the basic instructions which are so simple but very easy to
forget,
it can be very useful.
I like the idea of
it being like bicep curls for your mind.
Yeah.
Hmm.
I mean,
you see,
you see it in the brain scans and Samuel correct me where I run a foul of
scientific accuracy here,
but this base,
this,
um,
simple act of sitting,
trying,
trying to focus on one thing at a time.
And then when you get distracted,
knowing you're distracted and returning to your breath is changing your brain.
When you do that,
you're boosting a,
the muscles,
the,
and then obviously the muscles.
When I'm using it as a light loosely,
you're boosting your focus muscle.
And in many cases,
whether there was a study in 2010,
I think it was done at Harvard,
uh,
that took people who had never meditated before and they scanned their brains
and then they had them do eight weeks of a,
I think,
a half hour a day of meditation.
At the end of the eight weeks,
they scanned their brains again.
What they found was in the area of the brain associated with self awareness,
the gray matter grew,
and in the area of the brain associated with stress,
the gray matter shrink.
That to me is pretty compelling.
Okay.